and we have tiffany here hi tiffany  wearing my favorite color hi  all right so what's it going to be a  truth or a dare i actually have a truth  for you today ross oh oh okay let me  stretch what is it okay so ross what is  the worst mistake you've ever made on  live tv oh okay  all right i love it  i've been doing this for a minute right  on live tv but i've never sworn ever but  you know interviewing celebrities you  messed up a couple times and one time i  didn't know i was going to be able to  interview dame elizabeth taylor and i  accidentally called her dame edna on air  which was uh she was a drag queen  so that did not go well for me tiffany  oh my gosh i am so glad you asked that  is the best story ever and i said it  real loud like damn  [Applause]  i love it tiffany you just made my day  thank you so much  for choosing to spend your time with us  we make this show for you so  take it with you  [Music]